JavaScript includes many different syntaxes and
techniques to accomplish the same goals.
Just thinking about what we learned about objects alone,
there are at least three different ways of defining objects.
Literal, dot, and bracket notation.
When you start debugging other people's code,
you're going to have to wade through almost two decades of different syntax and
techniques, layered one on top of the other.
>> You know what?
This sounds like a great quiz to me.
This course isn't long enough to introduce everybody to all of
the nuances of JavaScript.
In fact, you could spend more than a hundred hours in a JavaScrip class without
getting a complete picture of the language.
>> Yeah.
I think I see where you're going with this.
Let's give students a piece of JavaScript, with some syntax they haven't yet
encountered, and see if they can figure it out.
>> This piece of code should look familiar.
You saw something similar a few exercises ago,
when you're tracking click locations on a website.
There's this weird syntax here, with function, location, console.log, etc.
What is going on here?
What is document.click taking as a parameter?
Do some research, try testing it out in DevTools, and
put your thoughts right here.